what about your [__] hair is that
real it's real baby yeah be real oh yeah
no plugs [__] no I'm working on a Kirk
Fox too you want to see it all right I
mean it's so good it's so good it's so
good just doing oh my God it's so good
well it's got to be good man my God it's
so good wow you're great are there
donuts coming or ar that's great hey be
tired for the right reason it's so good
is Impressions hard I don't consider
myself an impression I know I know but
you do you're so good at the Kirk one I
like did the other day and I was like I
I think I can see if I can see the
person and then it's right yeah um I've
never I've tried in the mirror but it's
like I can't do it no not one at all
like do a Sebastian I can't even do it
give me a give me one line maybe I can
do it okay how about this say uh say
yeah see that's the start you're doing
something with your face so you're
transforming and he's
Donuts that's it yeah why you so I I
can't do it yeah yeah why so what though
what are you going to say I so you do
donuts and let me repeat after you okay
okay yeah yeah donut Donuts I always
sound asan when I do impression donut
donut donut well that's going be you
know you here's an impression that you
did in when we were the DC Improv I
don't know if you've ever actually done
this bit I don't know if I talked about
this last time where we were at the DC
Improv and we're walking around all The
Monuments and we're at the Martin Luther
King uh the Lincoln Memorial remember
this and I go and he goes we're standing
up there and he goes he goes he goes we
need a um a Korean Martin Luther King
and then he goes I have a
dreaming that one day white people will
do the own dry cleaning oh and I was
like yeah do you do that no I go I have
a dreamings you mean that why people
will do their own
laundry you impression yeah maybe that's
not an impression that's a a guy with an
Asian accent right okay so okay so mas
and donuts um uh I don't know he's
almost yeah about this let's double it
up but the hand thing is good let's do
an as do an Asian
Sebastian monos Scala okay see if you
can do it you tried to you tried to have
me do this at the tiger B remember we
did that that girl not no so I'm in so
I'm in listen listen I was fully ready
to alternate universe right you know
standup is huge in China yeah right I'm
in the audience and there's a guy named
uh Chia
manang Chia manang yeah Chango right and
I'm here I love Chango yeah he's
reservations I yeah right yes oh there
he is he going up on stage
y
y a little Asian accent it can't just be
straight
Italian
Donuts wa more thick Rea donut
donut yeah yeah when you put all the
icing on you got to be very very careful
[__] I don't know clip it clip it I love
it I love it I love it anyway I don't
think that's my strongest accent it's
fine better yeah
yeah yeah I just that's you doing um I
think your your dad when you do that